former socialite convicted of leading
teenage girls to be sexually abused by
jeffrey epstein will be sentenced today
prosecutors want gallane maxwell to
serve 30 years or more in prison now her
lawyers say she deserves far less
maxwell denies abusing anyone our
national correspondent jerica duncan is
outside the new york city courthouse
where maxwell will learn her fate
jericho good morning to you what time is
the hearing and what are you expecting
gail we expect to hear from women who
said they survived the abuse of jeffrey
epstein and galaine maxwell all of this
is really a culmination of accusations
which led to a conviction and now it is
up to a judge as to how much time delay
maxwell will face behind bars
six months after galen maxwell's guilty
verdict she will learn if she will
likely spend the rest of her life behind
bars for recruiting and luring teen
girls as young as 14 to be sexually
abused by her longtime confidant jeffrey
epstein four victims testified against
her at trial among them annie farmer who
told the court maxwell at one point
fondled her breast at epstein's new
mexico ranch in her victim impact
statement she is expected to tell the
court today the number of people harmed
is impossible to measure and ask the
judge to consider the quote ongoing
suffering of the many women abused and
exploited by maxwell including annie's
sister maria farmer maria wasn't part of
this trial but in 2019 she told cbs's
anthony mason that epstein and maxwell
sexually assaulted her i
i hate her more
you hate land more way more because
because she's a woman and she fed women
to him maria worked the front desk in
epstein's new york city townhouse in the
1990s when she was 26 years old i saw
guilan going to get the women she went
to places like central park i was with
her a couple times in the car and she
would dash out and get a child what did
she say she was doing when she did this
getting victoria's secret models but
maxwell's lawyers have argued she only
became a target when epstein died by
suicide in 2019 while awaiting trial
this judge knows this case inside and
out cbs news legal expert ricky clemen
says it's highly unlikely that maxwell
will get the roughly five years her team
is seeking this judge is going to be
looking at a high end galaine maxwell is
likely
not going to get out of prison
at any kind of viable age for her to
live another new life
maxwell's attorneys say that she was put
on unjustified suicide watch over the
weekend which they say hindered her
ability to prepare for today's
sentencing which is of course still
going forward tony
all right thank you very much